foreign
Oak Virginia and talk to the great and
wonderful Rachel what's up Rachel
hey Dr John how are you so good how are
you
I'm good thank you for taking my call
awesome thank you for calling what's up
yes and as as I'm talking to you you
realize that I've been practicing my
questions to you in my head all morning
hey it's practice is good it practice is
good go for it what's up all right okay
so um my husband and I have been married
married for 15 years and over the years
whenever I have conflict with anybody
from his side of the family so whether
it's mother-in-law or any of the four
constraint laws or anybody from his side
of the family I tend to channel the
frustration or the anger from those
conflicts towards my husband even though
it has nothing to do with him or he has
no involvement in those conflicts I
Channel it towards him and the way I
justify is hey he's part of that family
so he deserves this kind of treatment
from me and I know it's totally crazy
totally unfair so my question to you is
how do I Channel my frustration away
from people I love and I guess even more
importantly how do I get it out of my
system with my questions if that makes
sense yeah I think that you're operating
on a bad model
um
it's a very
um I'm not saying this in a derogatory
way this is like I'm trying to say this
clinically it's a very child based
response
I'm mad about this over here so I'm
gonna spit on you all right this thing
happened to me from this guy I'm gonna
kick you
right or you see kids they stub their
toe at a door and then they punch a
chair right like I'm gonna go get that
thing
that's a very childish response it comes
from an eight so
um the bad model is that they get it out
model is been proven faulty it's not
real
there was a whole there was decades
where they would tell you to quote
unquote get your anger out that's a
thing you have to get out you have to
and you they have these they even have
them now they got smash rooms and yell
rooms and I have to tell you what you
did I gotta say all these things I have
to get this out of my body
um what the research tells us is what it
does is it actually reinforces those
neural Pathways and makes them stronger
it makes the the the connections more
reinforced
so every time you take your anger on
your husband your body reinforces that
as the appropriate way of getting of
making yourself feel better which is to
hit somebody else to spit on somebody
else
and the only way to break that there's
not a way to getting it out the only way
to break that is to grieve it which I
don't think you've ever done and
um decide I'm not going to act this way
and eventually over time you teach your
body different levels different ways to
deal with that stress whether it's going
for a walk whether that is writing in a
journal whether that's playing your
guitar whether that's any going dancing
any number of things
but you have to make the choice I'm
going to stop hitting my husband for
other things people are doing I'm gonna
stop spitting in his face for something
his father did
now anytime somebody asks me this I
always have to ask
has he done the work of drawing firm
boundaries with his family
he has yes
okay
yeah and they continue to violate those
boundaries
it's not all the time it's you know some
things never
what you actually have to do is to cut
off contact because they are opting out
of relationship with you and what you
really want is you want both and
you want to tell them what your
boundaries are and have them honor them
and they are not
and that makes them not real boundaries
that makes y'all just annoying
Chihuahuas just barking a lot
yeah that's what it sounds like usually
yeah it's instead of saying okay
we've been very clear we won't talk
about X we've been very clear we don't
like it when you use that language we've
been very clear we can't travel on Days
A B and C because of whatever
um
and you all have opted out of
relationship with us it breaks our heart
we're really sad about that
and I hate going that route because then
it's kind of you're losing your family
right your family left you they left you
Rachel
you're just continuing to let them drag
you behind down behind the truck down
the street
and you're getting mad at them about the
road rash but the whole time you're
hanging onto the Rope
yeah
that's where I say you have to grieve
this whole thing often that that feeling
that I have to get this out that's often
not anger that's grief
yeah it wasn't supposed to be like this
I was supposed to get married and I was
going to be best friends with his mom
and me and his dad he was going to treat
me like his another daughter and we're
going to tell inappropriate jokes and
laugh and have inside jokes and none of
that happened
very true you have to spend some time
being really freaking heartbroken about
that and you haven't and when you're not
when you skip over grief when you skip
over heartbreak it comes out as rage
and you just start hitting the person
closest to you which happens to be the
man you love right
right
so you have to decide to spend some time
and grief and that is not fun
but also hurting your husband over
something he's not doing isn't fun
either
and grief has a weird way of clarifying
your next step
as David Kessler says you end up finding
meaning here's my next PATH it's how
after
um a young high school kid gets killed
by a drunk driver and after three or
four years his mom ends up
starting a non-profit or his mom ends up
going to speak at local high schools or
his dad becomes goes back to law school
to whatever
you find your body directs you you find
meaning there
and that might be where you're like you
know what for me and my house we're
going to choose joy and laughter we're
not going to choose to go back into this
so we're going to find other wise adults
that honor our boundaries and that we
love and that love us and that's what
we're going to spend most of our time
because sadly for us our families are
opting out of relationship with us or
after grieving
then it's like you know what we can just
go to these things and roll our eyes I
don't really care if you're talking
about politics or whatever give me an
example of a thing they do that just
makes you enraged
um sometimes so when we see them
sometimes they would comment on my kids
you know being either you know they're
too skinny for what they think they
should weigh type thing they would want
to opine on my personal life uh things
like that
why do you care what they think
why do you give them access to your your
inner core being like that
that's where I struggle is I don't know
how to block that I don't like it it's
uh it's not a blocking it's just like uh
I guess maybe it's a blocking
I'm trying to think of a mental model
for that it's not like you're Teflon
those things like come into you like
they just don't register the same
it's like when they say it it just gets
stuck with me that every time I see them
those conversations rerun in my head and
then I get all that build up emotionally
are they saying it because they don't
like you and they're being mean are they
saying it because they genuinely care
about those kids and think they need to
know I think fatten them up I mean I
think yeah I think over the years they
always had a hard time accepting me as
part of the family there you go it's
been 15 years
it's not fine it is not fine because you
are
that is Rippling through
your relationship with them
they've never liked you and they're
never gonna like your kids they're not
gonna like how your kids look they
didn't like how you looked they had a
different picture of another woman in in
mind for their son and he picked you
and
they had another picture of what their
grandkids were going to look like not
the ones they got not those skinny
little things and so they're gonna they
have opted out
see what I'm saying
yeah
and what you and your husband have to do
is really grieve that because that's not
supposed to be like that
is it supposed to be like that
yeah
and it breaks my heart because it hurts
my husband yes and the last thing I want
to do is hurt him you're not his parents
are I know but it's because of me right
nope he chose you
he loves you to the moon and back he
loves you to the end of time
it's because his parents act like
children
and his parents don't actually fully
love their son
his parents loved the role their son
played in making their life perfect
you're right about that very true about
that they've been doing that to him his
entire freaking life
yep
and so what y'all have done is you'll
verbalized a lot of boundaries but you
haven't lived them out
in a perfect world your husband sits
down with your parents and says for 15
years you have not accepted or loved my
wife
and for 15 years you've made little
quips and comments and pokes and prods
and now those pokes and prods are
rubbing off on my kids
and I let my wife down
because I let it go on for years without
saying anything or saying hey we don't
like that but not really do anything
about it
and now that I'm seeing it with my kids
I realized I was wrong to not get more
vocal with my wife and especially I'm
gonna draw around with my kids
if y'all say these things again and
don't fully accept my wife don't fully
accept my kids don't fully accept our
family
you are choosing for us to not come here
and we will get that message loud and
clear
that's what he should say
and that is not a conversation for you
to have that's a conversation for him to
have
right
but until he decides to stop being a
action figure
and his mom and dad's little Playhouse
they're going to continue to try to
exert control over every aspect of his
life
even the appearance of his kids
and we have made it clear over and over
and you know when they make comments I
know but you keep going you keep showing
up yeah you keep showing up
you keep showing up and that's not
that's not
your parents have learned oh they're
just gonna they're gonna they're all
bark no bite
they're all they're all barks they're
not gonna actually leave
so we can do whatever we want
we're going to continue to push and poke
and poke and push and push and poke
until one of the grandkids says
something back or one day Rachel says
something back
and then it's going to confirm at C told
you she's a fill in the blank told you
she's just like everyone else who fill
in the blank
don't give him that
now I also want to be careful because
there's a whole ecosystem now it's like
you just if they don't if they don't
whatever your boundaries you just
abandon them and run away not
necessarily this is 15 years
15 years and my gut tells me there's a
racial component to this there's all
kinds of other layers to this
that um kind of ooged me out and grosses
me out pisses me off
and especially when it rolls off of our
son supposed to make us happy and he
didn't follow our directions
and um so now we're going to throw
grenades at his kids no way no way
no way
the job you have to do Rachel is grieve
this number one
because it should be different
your in-laws should be so excited that
the sun they raised
this man that they raised
with good judgment and character and
kindness pick you
and they should be so even if you look
different you appear different you are
whatever it should be so excited that
he's head over heels in love with her
and it looks different but it's painting
time because we're painting a new
picture because this is our new life
we're gonna get to know her and learn
about her
and then when those kids come along oh
my gosh you were big and huge and
muscular when you were a kid and your
kids were skinny little
it's that's a totally different
conversation then you know what they
should be what are you feeding man
you're gonna spend some time in grief
and you are gonna have to open your
hands up and realize that you can't
control the world and you're trying to
control how your husband feels how your
in-laws feel you can't
they're grown adults
but you do have to also decide I'm gonna
stop spitting on my husband because his
parents are children
I'm gonna stop punching my husband
metaphorically
because his parents hurt my feelings
but you also have to sit down your
husband and say we have to end this we
have to we have to create some space
here because it's hurting our marriage
it's hurting our relationship with our
kids and we can't let outside
influencers do that
behavior is a language
and it sounds like your in-laws are
telling you we don't want you or those
kids around
and if your husband has any integrity at
all he says cool
Bye Felicia we going he leaves
hopefully he sits down with him and has
a final direct conversation
but you're not the crazy one Rachel
spend some time in grief
it's been some time in heartache
write him a letter don't ever ever send
it or write him a letter about what you
really feel
and how heartbroken you are
that's step one
then get a couple of friends and read it
to him that's step two